[Music]
you're seeing Trump bandy around the
term fake news to describe some of our
most venerated venerable trustworthy
institutions when the president is
calling anything he doesn't like fair
fake news arm yeah it dislocates the
term it dislocates the idea i think you
know in general what we're seeing is an
assault on the idea that there can be
objective truth um the idea that
anything can stand above the political
fray and you know he's seizing on that
but it comes out of a much you know it
comes out of the polarization that the
coverage and the news media has been
mired in for a good long time and he's
opportunistically seizing on it but he
didn't invent it right we've been in the
air for a long time now of polarized
Talking Heads spewing venom at each
other on you know cable news shows in
what is supposed to be a you know a fair
and balanced and kind of like equal
playing field situation but because
objectively speaking some of these
people are dealing with facts and others
are dealing with invented imagined
biased nonsense there's often you know
creating that illusion of a balanced
playing field is difficult like you can
turn on the news and see like you know a
fair and balanced discussion of climate
change and like on this side we have
like this dude who's got like you know a
doctorate in physics from Oxford and is
like you know a triple PhD in every
relevant field and wrote six books all
of which won the Pulitzer Prize and
representing the other side is like Joe
schmucko from Illinois who like thinks
global warming doesn't exist because he
has a snowball in his freezer some
you know like and these people are being
presented as if they have equal
credentials so you know the polarization
that leads to the dislocation of truth
you know it's got to be the blame for it
needs to be spread around like it's been
going on for a good long time yeah I
mean satire is an incredibly powerful
tool and weapons
arm and it I think we're in an age where
satire seems outdated it'll come back
around but at the moment we are living
in such an absurd world Trump and his
administration his cabinet his cronies
defy satire because they are more
ridiculous than anything that our
greatest satirical Minds can come up
with so as you say we've moved into a
phase where you know right now satire is
not for the masses satire is directed
only at the president like Alec
Baldwin's entire audience on Saturday
Night Live is essentially Trump we're in
a moment where Trump's own advisors are
letting it be known that the way that
they have to get his attention is to go
on television he won't listen to them if
they're in the same room together so
they go on you know TV hoping that he
will see them and listen because he
apparently only pays attention to things
and people that he hears on screen so
you know I think there's a very real
sense in which both the satire and the
entire sort of talking head
infrastructure is increasingly directing
itself solely at him it's like you know
this guy watches TV all the time he gets
his news he gets his information not
from intelligence briefings not from you
know this treasure trove of classified
information that most people would be
fascinated to delve into but from the
same idiots that everybody else has
access to maybe satire isn't dead that's
pretty absurd in itself I take it back
that's how it's very much alive in the
form of Trump you know an audience of
one for everything that goes on in the
media
you